welcome back to new rock stars hawkeye
episode 5 finally confirmed who the big
guy is in the you know tiniest way
possible via nft that's the best way to
reveal a bad guy via vanity but what
does this mean for this show's big
finale and the future of the mcu this is
rogue theory the show where we pitch the
wildest theories for the nerdy titles we
love my name is mt and going rogue with
me today is my go-to partner for any
avengers level threat it's jessica
clemens what's going on jess oh i'm the
partner i mean you're looking mad kate
bishop today gotta say ooh
ooh
kingpin are you perfect
you kingpin i am kingpin
waiting
[Laughter]
exactly
and also joining us is the owner of
multiple secret shell companies it's
whitney van liningham what's going on
whitney
man all my shell companies are doing so
well
so well let me tell you well let me tell
you
all of the shells every single one just
in time
evaded so many
so many laws being broken can't wait
can't wait to tell you all about them
and finally royal tenonbomb superfan
it's tom michaelson what's going on
bro how's it going bro nice seeing you
guys bro got my i got my bro bro my
ronin uh look ready to go just in case
[Applause]
dragons
bros
the hawkeye series has been building and
building to some inevitable villain
reveals with episode 5 confirming the
show's biggest mystery uncle is indeed
vincent and afrial as wilson fisk aka
kingpin aka uncle willie leader of the
tracksuit mafia he betrayed maya lopez's
father and is in cahoots with eleanor
and potentially even val which brings us
to our first question how will hawkeye
end like how will kate bishop and
clinton barton respond to kingpin's
involvement in this crisis and what new
grudges and alliances will form by the
end of this series take it away all
right well i have to say that my dream
like finale for this show
um would be
the larpers facing off with the
tracksuit mafia like
center yes chris yo you know that's
gonna happen and it's gonna be amazing i
just can't wait i just honestly cannot
wait for that moment i mean except a
little nervous that girls might die
cause you know that happened oh my god
that's all i can think about when i i
know i love him so much him so much and
i just don't want him to die and also if
he dies
who's gonna think of another name for
pizza dog i know
see i'm afraid that they're setting it
up like i thought of a name and then
like his last words gonna be like his
name's lucky
but no oh my god i would love to see the
larpers in the in this tracksuit
dracula's mafia whatever you want to
call them go head-to-head i didn't even
think of that because how you could have
the other guy in the background
tracksuit oh i'm here for it yes now i
need to see that listen man don't [ __ ]
around with larpers they are an intense
crowd oh yeah they have a variety of
items they sure do they have items they
have powers they've got little outfits
it's like it's like whose little outfits
are better the tracksuits are the
larpers it's true i hope we have a
fashion show as the post-credits scene
of all this just
same do you think that any of the track
suits will enjoy it so much that they
will take up larping
you know what i could very much see that
i would love that because like i like
converts towards the end and they're
like bro what are we doing working for
kingpin we could just larp like
let's join the new york fire department
i love it i love it
all right what
what you guys got um yeah i think that
this is definitely all of a sudden all
these chess pieces are coming into place
like with kingpin now on the table
uh there
i don't think he's gonna end up being
too big of a you know big bad in this
show because they can't waste them just
with one up left if this was like a 12
12
episode arc maybe they would have a lot
more hit but this is just kind of a
little easter egg saying that this is
coming down the line because vincent
d'onofrio being in the mcu is too big of
a piece so i think they're going to set
him up
to be like in the background maybe uh
coming up in she-hulk you know where you
know another lawyer matt murdock might
be showing up now that charlie cox has
been confirmed
yeah and i think the other thing that i
couldn't uh that you know i know jess
will have a lot to say about this but i
couldn't help but uh
notice is when you know kate and elena
have such chemistry on screen and i was
like man they need to be the new
uh at least the very least the new clint
and natasha friendship the new hot guy
the new black widow because she even you
know she even didn't take that shot on
yelena like you're like clint didn't
take that shot on natasha
yeah so if we're seeing the beginning of
this friendship that'll take us with
another 10 years of the mcu i'm here for
it because yeah that was such a fun
scene so good
i agree top three five mcu scenes yes
can i just say she is a goddamn queen
for putting sriracha on her mac and
cheese like so do i that's the best way
to eat it yeah and now mcu cannon that
that is the best way to eat
cheese so look
okay
hot sauce okay my mac and cheese because
i like my mac and cheese southern but
sriracha's okay on mac and cheese
sriracha spicy we're all a little spicy
fam here we're all spicy bros yeah
listen any spicy really i'm not i'm not
gonna discriminate against some other
types of hot sauces i'm interested you
want to get me a sample i will put it in
my mouth
yes sriracha hot sauces literally if i
were to you know oh be cut open right
now sriracha would bleed out just
flowing literally my blade my my blood
dude you'd come in real handy to uh to
elena then because she could just kill
you and go right into dinner time right
you can have haley steinfeld but leave
me elena empty
okay you know what we can we can go with
this
but i get you like okay we can double
date it'll be a great double date
perfect but no what do you think jeff
how do you feel i
look i agree with tom
i agree with tom i think that this uh
you can't kill i was thinking about this
after the episode i was like
kingpin is such a big character you
cannot just wipe him out like i i hate
to mention this but i will not have what
happened to taskmaster like you are
going to keep this character going for a
moment
so i'm truly like he has to stay so why
i think he's got to stay is i think
we're going to see echo kill that person
that was honestly in on her dad getting
murdered for her like right-hand man i
think they're going to kill them and
then they're going to be like sad and
we're going to get the a better version
of echo in the series and then we're
going to get kingpin is somehow
somehow i think clint is going gonna be
kidnapped i don't think it's gonna end
well for clint at the end of the season
because we are gonna get that yelena and
kate bishop team up and because elena is
the person that's like i gotta do this
on my own but kate bishop's like no we
need to be a team i'm a child and
elena's like we're the same age but i
act like a mature child i guess but i
think we're gonna get that team up that
is gonna go eventually somewhere to go
save clint but i just don't think
that
like kingpin can die yet like he's gonna
stay on so
if there is a down
um
it's too it's so and it sucks because
there's only six episodes so i'm like if
there were nine i feel like we'd get a
lot more with this kingpin situation
that makes it okay for him to exit but
he can't so i think something bad has to
happen to clint or his family one of the
two i don't think it's gonna be death i
think it's just gonna be like the end of
the series clinton's gonna get a call
and kingpin's gonna be there with his
family on christmas day or something um
i just think it has to be
it has to be something like that so
ultimately i agree with tom i i agree
full-heartedly i want to see that team
up with yelena and kate
okay okay okay and one thing i was
thinking about too uh just to add is i i
can't help but think that kate's father
is alive
like his no his death was too quick
and it was never mentioned they never
showed never trust an off-screen dad
exactly you can
and he said he would do anything to keep
kate safe and you know we know that they
were about to go bankrupt maybe he
faked his death for the insurance money
they helped build the shadow empire and
we also know from the comics her dad was
on the villain panel with kingpin in the
comic that put out the hit on hawkeye so
two things
two things two things
i was like i was thinking about the
comics and i was thinking how they like
to shake it up a lot for the series they
don't like to keep it too grounded from
the comics so what if kingpin is her dad
a that's what i was thinking about i was
like oh god either that would be like so
bad like so crazy either that's king
bishop's dad and he faked his death
because he's gone into crime or he's
always been in crime and
a lot eleanor is just really great as a
right-hand man or or and i just tweeted
this because i was like i've been
thinking about this ever since the fifth
episode what if eleanor bishop is a
black widow and she actually did kill
her dad kate bishop's dad because he was
supposed to be killed and she's just
been like i've been killing and rising
to the top because we saw the other
black widow who's just living her life
her best life and she's like yeah i'm
just
here living so what if we have another
rogue black widow which is eleanor
bishop boom yeah yeah yeah yeah that's
pretty good and that would make you you
get something
definitely
yes know if you guys noticed in like the
first episode too that some of the like
framed like pictures and stuff in their
house were of eleanor doing like very
acrobatic things like she's like clearly
very she's athletic she's she's
yeah
and so that could be widow training man
this is true that she definitely has
some type of agility because we saw in
like one of the first episodes episode
one i believe yeah of her doing that
weird trick yeah what she caught like
you know i feel like that was
foreshadowing like some type of like and
she's like yeah it's cute
it's cute watch this really hard trick i
can do
it's so cute and i'll kill you later
foreshadowing
but no for sure i really like that
connection because like eleanor could
100 be a black widow i never really
thought of that and like she could she
does have some type of skill i feel yeah
so i i'm gonna give i want to give just
that
that the larpers and the tracksuit mafia
are going to team up or like some type
of interaction's gonna happen because
they're just two there's two great
groups
two great groups
two
those are some great both sides
both sides
awesome
these bad things about both sides
oh my god
but um but no but before we continue um
just one more thing about val what what
how do you guys think that val is going
to factor into all this in the finale
well i'm wondering if you know how at
the end of falcon winter soldier she was
telling um
the
[ __ ] captain america as i like to
call him uh she was telling him that
he's like very valuable to somebody else
that she works with and i'm wondering if
that was a reference to kingpin and that
she might be working with him she might
be trying to
collect super-powered people so maybe
like you said if cl or yeah like if
clint does get taken
and kidnapped maybe that's uh that's
part of it because she's trying to
collect all those uh all the the rogue
the rogue folks the rogue heroes and
ronan would be great for her collection
and it's interesting because like yeah
you know everybody including myself was
like you know val works for
ross and this is going to be a
thunderbolts type thing but
if by saying that eleanor hired the
elena and if val was the one to deliver
the
the the hit job you know now maybe val
works for the kingpin
um and this could be you know the
kingpin again operating kind of from the
shadows maybe with a public face then
that building that eleanor was going
into that yelana was watching i was like
is this fisk tower is now that you know
avengers tower and like now maybe you
know it's big willie style and he's
gonna be having his own anti-avengers
coming out big winners tower right
um
yeah it's i it's crazy because val i
think may or maybe she's playing a lot
of sides but the fact that she's like
has a direct link to kingpin
kind of changes things too for her and
where she's coming from this is true
this is true all right all right you got
anything jess i am double checking this
before i say it because i don't want to
come off offensive uh give me one no no
it is not big willie's style
[Applause]
i don't want to assume i don't want to
disagree with tommy
um
yeah nope i would have been late nope
this would have been wrong uh you know
what i don't have anything
it would have been it wasn't bad it
wasn't bad my whole link i was like i
think it'd be fun if val instead of
having a connection
we don't know where he is right now but
if she would had a connection to jacques
before she had a connection to anybody
else and jacques is just
not doing a good job
but
because now he's in jail so who knows
when he's getting back out but oh
we'll go okay the next rogue question i
have a theory for this okay okay sorry
keep going okay well these are all great
theories but up next we are going to
theorize about where the end of hawkeye
and its new characters could lead us in
future marvel properties but first there
is a new latest obsession shirt inspired
by hawkeye available at new
rockstarsmirch.com has a cool design
that comes in three colors and is
officially the best shirt to wear while
watching new hawkeye episodes find those
shirts and all other great merch options
at newrockstarsmerch.com
but hey if you dread looking at your
credit card statements you're not alone
the weight of debt can be crippling but
upstart can help you on your path to
financial freedom upstart is a fast and
easy way to pay off your debt with a
personal loan all online whether it's
paying off credit cards consolidating
high interest debt or funding personal
expenses over a million people have used
upstart to get one fixed monthly payment
with a clear payoff date rather than
looking at credit score alone upstart
considers other factors like your income
current employment and credit history to
find you a smarter rate for your loan
and you can check out your rate without
impacting your credit score in minutes
for loans between one thousand to fifty
thousand dollars and you can even
receive funds as fast as one business
day after accepting your loan so find
out how upstart can lower your monthly
payments today when you go to
upstart.com rogue that's upstart.com
rogue don't forget to use our url to let
them know that we sent you loan amounts
will be determined based on your credit
income and certain other information
provided in your loan application
upstart.com rogue and this winter
upgrade your daily routine with bespoke
post and their new seasonal lineup of
must-have box of awesome collections
bespoke post partners with small
businesses and emerging brands to bring
you the most unique goods every month
they have great sweaters and cooking
gear that's great for a long winter's
night and no matter what you're into box
of awesome has you covered from winter
cocktails to cozy threads and camping
gear essentials box of awesomes has
collections for every part of your life
the cask box comes with a handmade oak
barrel to make smoky cocktails the forge
box has a damascus steel knife made by
buck and bear knives in pennsylvania to
get started take the quiz at box of
awesome.com your answers will help them
pick the right box of awesome for you
and they release new boxes every month
it's free to sign up and you can skip a
month or cancel any time each box costs
only 45 bucks but has over 70 dollars
worth of gear inside 90 of everything
that comes in your box of awesome is
from a small up-and-coming brand get 20
off your first monthly box when you sign
up at box of awesome.com and enter the
code rogue at checkout that's box of
awesome.com code rogue for 20 off your
first box to maximize your time savoring
holiday moments and to minimize your
time shopping for gifts check out mac
weldon they have the great threads to
make you look sharp at any holiday party
and we're talking top-notch tops
best-selling bottoms and underwear and
accessories that will please even the
scrooges guys on your list with mack
weldon your holiday heavy lifting will
be complete within minutes their a
sweatshirts and warm knit collection are
perfect for your holiday routine and for
gifts they're incredibly comfortable and
warm and great for lounging in front of
a fire bridging movies but they also
look great so you can wear them to
events mac weldon's warm knit collection
that features shirts vests and more uses
innovative technology to keep you at the
perfect temperature mack weldon has
great gift sets that are the perfect
present for any guy in your list this
holiday season every guy deserves to
wear unforgettable clothes that he loves
for the moments with loved ones that
he'll never forget that's why mac walden
is always on my holiday list for giving
and getting for 20 off your first order
visit macweldon.com rogue and enter
promo code rogue that's macweldon.com
rogue promo code rogue for 20 off mac
weldon get it right this holiday season
so on to our second topic because you
just don't introduce a villain like
kingpin for only one episode of one
disney plus series like he was worth
pulling out of the netflix storage
closet so surely marvel has plans for
him beyond hawkeye which leads us to our
second question of the day when will we
see kingpin next in the mcu after this
series
can i can i
this might be a minute but i was
thinking about this on my in a car ride
i was thinking about this so ultimately
i do think we're gonna see him again in
armor wars and why i think it's a great
idea to see him in armor wars is because
if you guys saw the mandarin short
that's on disney plus you see at the end
when it was when the actual well not the
original and the mandarin got uh ben
kingsley out of jail at the end you see
justin hammer is still in prison and
justin hammer is in that prison short so
i think in armor wars we're gonna see
this is if and this might be bad [ __ ]
out of my mind i might not have the
timeline correctly right down thinking
but i think this is kingpin is in jail
so this is a little bit before hawkeye
because i think because now that kingpin
is out of jail i think he was in jail
with justin hammer with ben kingsley and
because we see that walter goggins is um
is like said to be in armor wars he's
also in prison with the rest of them so
i think we're gonna see him in armor
wars and they all had a plan that plan
was to steal clint and they're still
working together to do all of these
things i think walter goggins and
ant-man and wass worked for kingpin when
kingpin was in prison and all of these
gangs are all attached to kingpin so i
think we will see him in armor worth i
think we'll absolutely see him in echo
especially in flashbacks but i think
armor wars is a big take to like really
think about him being in because if this
is the king of kings the king of gangs
the king of kings the king of kings we
need to think about everybody that was
in prison working on the low and if
we're getting walter goggins and walton
walter what goggins uh sunny birch from
ant-man and wasp that's gonna be in
armor wars i think they were all in
there doing some sneaky shady [ __ ] to
get him out and once he got out we see
him in hawkeye and he's like i'm out of
prison i'm here to [ __ ] [ __ ] up i don't
think he's gonna get that far because
we're getting into doctor strange
territory and it's like you got a gun
he's got magic but that's a different
story so that's why i think
he's going to do it
he's got magic who's going to really win
this he's going to be on a movie box
somewhere like i'm like on the cover you
got a gun i got magic so how about you
it's the buddy comedy between doctor
strange and kingpin
he's got a gun and he's got magic what
kind of wacky adventures will these hey
in the comics the punisher and dr
strange do team up briefly so that would
be great that would be good
[Laughter]
i guess that that theory wasn't so long
but i was just like
when i started reading into it and we
found out that walter goggins is in
armor wars i was like oh [ __ ] they're
trying to create like a really powerful
machine with justin hammer within the
prison walls and so
that's why i think we're gonna see
kingpin next that's awesome you know
yeah i don't have enough brain cells to
think like that damn
come on whitney
you got it
i love that because you know if they if
they're bringing in the continuity from
the mcu you know yeah kingpin was in
jail by the end of season three so you
could totally have all these people in
the same place at the same time hatching
the same scheme that's really great i
was actually thinking that they might
you know treat that as a variant
universe and being like now that we've
already told the audience this is how
this is how variants work that's how the
multiverse works you know this is our
wilson fisk who you know who uh never
had those problems you know he has
vanessa but there wasn't a um wesley or
whatever else they could pick and choose
now what they want from the netflix
series at work so
uh so i think that they might have this
kingpin maybe having never gone to jail
yeah working operating in the shadows
and kind of
putting everything in place and i think
he might operate maybe even in a thanos
type way where they're planting the seed
now
for you know years from now where will
it'll really pay off and so i'm
wondering if he'll end up being the big
bad for the echo show because you know
he you know echo and uh you know kingpin
definitely have some history there and
yeah he's not like kingpin's gonna be
the bad guy in you know multiverse of
madness you know i mean he could but
he's more of a street level hero and so
for all the upcoming street level folks
you know even moon knight to some extent
or but yeah like she-hulk and echo and
every other show maybe even some armor
wars with uh i think that's where he's
going to really show up and all these
like street level shows but still you
know pulling the strings and everything
and i love you tying it back just to
ant-man and then the wasp with walter
goggins you know um sunny birch and his
employer and all that stuff because yeah
there's
now that they've yeah now that they've
planted those seeds now oh yeah now we
can now we can watch it grow
i do like that i like it a lot i like it
a lot what you got whitney damn man i
just agree with you guys 10 million
uh the only thing that i'm like i don't
need to see him in this is i kind i like
very strongly hope that he doesn't have
a cameo in no way home just because
there are too many goddamn cameos and if
he has like if he has like an actual
like part like if he if he pops up i'm
cool with it if he has like a part i'm
like
god damn you spiderman no way home
there are so many people here
you guys invited everybody to this movie
peter and he's like swinging by like oh
i'm i'm busy just like yeah
i know i feel you whitney but like i'm
on the other end where i'm like there's
so many people but this might be the
last time we can get tom hall and
spider-man in the mcu and i would love
to for the kingpin and spidey to just
have a look i'm gonna be like look at
that wall crawler and he's just like
whoa dude and then just swing by because
we may not we may not ever get it one
thing i kind of mentioned on twitter
before is like
my my other fear is that the movie is
called spiderman no way home because
this might be you know the character
having no way home to the marvel
universe because sony has finished
lending their toys and they're gonna
bring us now that marvel's done all the
hard work and bringing their character
up and helping their spider-verse come
out with venom and morbius this is the
last time we're gonna see tom holland
proper in the mcu and they're gonna
bring him back to the sony verse i mean
we know that he's going to show up in
another mcu project but they might be
saving that for an avengers thing but
you know sony might be not willing to
share
yeah but i wanted to share anymore and
so i would hate to not ever see spidey
at least this spidey and this kingpin
together because vincent d'onofrio was
like what the best part of the daredevil
show and tom holland you know is some
bring some of the best spidey stuff
we've seen live action some of the best
don't don't kill me in the comments but
uh yeah so
i would love to see them at least have a
moment but i feel you whitney 100 and i
agree but also i'm like but we never see
it we may never see it though i know i
know listen okay i guess we're on the
same page because i'm like yes like a
little baby cameo would be cool but at
this point at the same time i'm just
like how many cameos can one move yeah
it can't be a big price
exactly it seems like every single day
it's like and this guy's in it and now
daredevil and now it's like no i really
hope
i really hope kingpin's in it um teaming
up with the rent guy from uh the remy
spiderman
[Laughter]
would be fat oh wait he is never mind
sorry
i met my daughter
were you gonna say something jess no
i'm sorry i don't remember what i was
gonna say i was thinking about
spider-man you got my brain thinking
about spiders spider-sense
but no all of those spider-man answers
are really cool because like they all
sort of line up with what i'm thinking
because like i think that uh this
kingpin is going to be a variant of the
netflix shows like we're not going to
see the exact same yeah
and i think that we'll we're likely to
see kingpin in armor wars because armor
wars is a huge deal we're dealing with
this piece of weaponry this stark
technology that all these criminals
definitely want um to to buy on the
black market so yeah for sure we're
going to see him in armored wars um in
my opinion so everybody is going to get
one point for that section because you
guys all just
you guys know what i feel you guys all
have a piece of what i feel inside so i
dig oh yeah guys there's nothing sexier
than confidence and blue chew can help
give you confidence where it counts blue
chew is a unique online service that
delivers the same active ingredients as
viagra and cialis but in chewable
tablets and at a fraction of the cost
you could take them any time date or
night so you can plan ahead or be ready
whenever an opportunity arises but the
process is simple sign up at
bluetooth.com consult with one of their
licensed medical providers and once
you're approved you'll receive your
prescription within days and the best
part it's all done online so no visits
to the doctor's office no awkward
conversations and no waiting in line at
the pharmacy blue chews tablets are made
in the usa and prepared and shipped
direct to your door in a discreet
package so if you could benefit for some
extra confidence when it's time to
perform blue chew can help and we got a
special deal for our audience try
bluetooth free when use our promo code
rogue at checkout just pay five dollars
shipping that's bluechew.com promo code
rogue to receive your first month free
visit bluetooth.com for more details and
important safety information and we
thank bluechu for sponsoring the show
but now it is time for
our rogue question guys are you ready
let's do it let's go bro let's do it
um because one division was the only
marvel series or film this year to
receive golden globe nominations it
received two nominations one for each of
its lead actors elizabeth olsen and paul
bettany so i want you to come up with
your rogueis made up golden globe award
that you can think of for any mcu
projects from this year that should have
been nominated for oh okay
okay it's kind of a very uh hard
question but you guys got this you guys
are smart cookies you want like a main
one
anything you want i was like it's not
too neat i don't want that
no i'm gonna make someone feel bad i
want there to be um
um i want there be or well it's not a
golden globe do you know the razzies
um they're like the awards for the worst
things i want there to be like biggest
waste of my time
taskmaster
taskmaster is freaking cool
and i got
i got bamboozled y'all tricked me and
i'm not over it i was so excited to
finally see this character on screen and
then you made fun of how she does the
poses and you didn't even have them do
the pose you didn't even have taskmaster
taskmaster
it's waste of time award taskmaster or
or honestly or honestly the the the
fighter and shang chi that got his soul
ripped out with it like oh my god
because we're hyping up the next big bad
and then whoops looks like you have to
wait for other content to build them up
yeah yeah
the death dealer one was kind of funny
so i take that one back that one cracked
me up it was really funny
okay yeah i know i would kind of agree
test master was kind of a letdown but
that's okay i mean like plenty of time
for that character to grow what do you
guys think and yeah i love the character
just to say for people in the comments i
get mad i love the character that's why
i was upset about it yeah what did you
guys get
let's see
well one one thing i was thinking about
is um
the
the in these shows one kind of uniform
thing that at least for me that's
happened there's always been a gut punch
moment like uh like oh like that the
feels moment and you could call it that
because in wanda vision it was
her and vision talking at the end and
him disappearing and falcon winter
soldier it was when bucky was finally
healed from that from the book in
wakanda and you know sebastian stan is
giving 110
you know and loki it was sylvie breaking
his heart at the very last second and in
this one i mean we we have one more app
but i feel like there's gonna be a
moment maybe
clint yeah uh clint not stopping elena
from killing him or something or that'll
just pull the rug out from under us and
be like oh so like you know i don't know
what you want to call it maybe yeah the
tear jerker
oh yeah lucky chucky's not lucky oh man
knock on wood that doesn't happen but
yeah you know no
no that can't happen that can't happen
but something happening that'll just
hit the you know tug at those
heartstrings and uh maybe we can call
you at the feels award because in the
empty these shows they may vary in
quality but they've all had some moments
that have just made you go oh god that's
like
it's it's yeah i don't know what you
call it but yeah the catharsis but also
the pain and the joy all in one moment
it's yeah i usually just call it
heartburn heartburn yeah oh god yeah the
bird the gerd award
[Laughter]
yeah what you got whitney all right i'm
gonna have to uh go with something from
hawkeye because i would like to give the
award for the comfiest most leisurely
villains to the tracksuit mafia you
gotta hand it to them at some point you
know that there was a time period where
they wore like
normal clothes to work they did and then
one day
one of them was like bro you know become
fear
and then they got everyone on board it's
like they have casual friday in their
organization every single day and like
i'm here for it if i only have to roll
out of bed and throw on a goddamn
tracksuit and then go murder someone and
get paid a bunch of money and live in a
cool house
come on they they the tracksuits
probably aren't even that expensive they
could spend all their kill money on
cooler things like
cocktails yeah they probably were like
hey bro have you seen the royal thin and
bronze girl pretty good movie bro the
next day they all came back with
traction like i like that movie too bro
it's pretty good yeah
i love that their idea of like oh i'm
gonna consume this media is i see myself
on screen and it's just cause it's
people interactions
no i love all of these answers but i
gotta give it to my boy tom because the
feels award is literally
a very good mcu award category to have
because that's all they do it's always
the feels i've always feel in touch with
some type of
weird fuzzy emotions
at the end i'm like yeah i didn't sign
up for this cabinet keep going
but he did oh man guardians too don't
get me started on gardens too yeah
i'd be
do we not remember that he basically
stole a child
to save a child
[Laughter]
could be his daddy nasty andrew daddy
that's true
well i think this leaves us with two
winners this episode uh jess and tom if
that my map is correct
it isn't
uh
yes if we have to pick one i'll go with
jess because i love the i love your
theories about jail and uh also the task
master's
i give away my points to talk i get my
time i get my question
um but all of you guys are amazing as
always and i love hearing from you guys
so thank you guys for coming on this
episode but that is it for this episode
of rogue theory thanks to our guests
jessica clemons whitney van lenningham
and tom michelson for coming on the show
support everything they do online and
support our channel by checking out all
of our awesome merch over at
newrockstarsmerch.com and hey if you
want to talk more about this episode of
work theory search for us on discord and
join some of the channels that we've
opened up to the public and we've made
some channels available to non-patrons
so you can be part of the broader
community of new rockstars fans on
discord so if you're over 18 and
interested search for new rockstars
discord server and join the conversation
thank you guys so much for watching
we'll see you guys later goodbye
[Music]
you